[Music]
thank you
20 free throws in a row ah
I thought he only made seniors do that
oh hey coach hello Miss Lou so uh Mari
show me what you got
sure
not bad I guess you're not the weak link
after
okay Lou you're up
seriously though great job
hey uh you okay yeah totally how come I
don't know why is coach always picking
on you
it's just a sense of humor
besides he's right I'm holding back the
team no you aren't
hey
did he touch you in the gym
um
you should really tell someone you trust
okay
text you later
bye
yeah yeah
oh that's yeah that's awful
seriously though
great job
yeah all right man we're talking about
this later bye two for two coach can we
talk yeah what's up I am I I appreciate
your help really but
it always makes me the center of
attention like it's just really awkward
look you're improving we're thinking
about starting you no what no
no what no I mean that's it's great
really
I just need you to stop treating me
differently stop giving me things and
and stop texting me on the weekends
and you have to stop touching me
I have no idea what you're talking about
seems like you're going through
something
maybe we shouldn't be starting you
but if anyone ever really does treat you
like that
make sure you tell someone okay
[Music]
ah
a
wow all right well that's all women in
space hey mate how do astronomers
organize a party huh
they plan it
oh I cracked myself up hey don't forget
planetarium field trip tomorrow
amazing right
[Music]
that could be you someday
Marty oh sorry distracted
everything all right
uh yeah
sorry have a good day Mr Ramirez
[Music]
foreign
I need to talk to you
[Music]
foreign
ah
[Music]
a
foreign
[Music]
this way kids come on
foreign
[Music]
what's going on
foreign
[Music]
you're safe
I'm here to help
okay
it's coach
he touched me
[Music]
I'm so sorry Marty do you want to go
talk to the counselor when we get back
to school I don't want to get anyone in
trouble
she probably won't believe me
well I believe you
hey this is not your fault
why don't we go together
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]